hi
i'm greg i'm the anthos gk security tech
lead at google
hi i'm samrad ray i'm the antho security
product management lead at google so
today we're talking about antho security
i wanted to start with the takeaways
that we're going to get from this
presentation
first up is we want you to be able to
understand how enthos improves security
across a hybrid in
production environment the next is
there's a lot of
products and features in this
presentation there's about 30
of them so we want to make sure that
we're being really obvious and
deliberate about
where each feature is available and
which environment and on which platform
it's available
but really the the high level thing we
want to leave you with here is a
four-step high-level workflow to config
figure endless security across
multiple different platforms just a
quick note
on names we've shortened some of the
names in this presentation just to make
things a bit easier to say and to fit
them on diagrams
so using gke for anthos on google cloud
this presentation is called modernize
your security posture so
what's being modernized and what
industry trends are driving that we
think there's these these three things
are happening
first is there's not just one production
security
infrastructure to harden anymore there's
multiple there's on-prem and there's
multiple clouds
second kubernetes and containers have
really changed a lot about
our security assumptions about
production infrastructure
so previously we might have had a
application running on a virtual machine
with always the same ip
whereas in kubernetes and containers we
have applications being dynamic
dynamically scaled
scheduled across different virtual
machines and with dynamically allocated
ips
and that's quite a difference to in
security properties
we also have these big monoliths that
have been broken down into microservices
and all those microservices now need
authentication and authorization to be
able to talk to each other
and that needs to happen inside the
perimeter so this is where nthos really
starts to come in and help if we look at
the
this hybrid infrastructure where we have
clusters running on google cloud
other clouds and on-prem the four
points at the top are really where
anthous is helping you
at the infrastructure level at a
separate policy layer
with services and application security
and with monitoring and detection
and so we took those four kind of
concepts and we turn them into these
four
steps that you can use to harden
applications and
and get to secure deployments across a
hybrid infrastructure
so the first step we're going to talk to
talk through
is hardening how do you do patching
compliance hardened configuration
next guardrails how do you segment
isolate
and apply that policy across lots of
clusters
securing workloads how do you only run
what you trust and have
really fine-grained authorization and
monitoring detection once you've done
all of that how do you find
misconfigurations and detect attackers
doing bad things to clusters
we want to be able to do these four
things across all of your different
environments
so let's start with hardening the
infrastructure and the spoiler for this
section is
we've basically done most of this for
you but we're going to talk through a
whole lot of work that's happening
behind the scenes so that you know that
it's happening
so starting with security patching and
hardening
if we look at a big stack of technology
for kubernetes clusters everything from
the hardware right up to application
containers
each one of these layers at some point
probably needs
security patching and it definitely
needs hardening
so when we're running on our own
infrastructure with gke
we've basically taken the responsibility
for most of that technology stack
for anthos that isn't gke so on-prem and
aws we're starting a little further up
because we're running on that
infrastructure that the customer has
provided
so the the vms running on-prem or the
virtual machines running in aws or other
clouds
so it's more of a responsibility
sandwich we would like to call this one
but we're still doing a lot of work in
the middle there
so when we do control that
infrastructure on gke we can deliver
some pretty cool
advanced security functionality that's
on by default or
is exposed with really simplified
configuration
so some of the things we're doing moving
from the bottom up in this diagram
the first thing we'll talk about is
shielded vms and nodes
so these features give us verifiable
integrity from our titan hardware
security chip
and the integrity of the the underlying
firmware and up through the kernel
and then we have the virtual tpm that
gives us a secure bootstrap and a way to
join the node to the cluster securely
customer manage encryption keys for disk
encryption
so every vm is encrypted automatically
by default
in google cloud with a key that is
managed by google internally
if you want to re-encrypt that vm again
and re-encrypt the disk again
you can do that using managed encryption
keys that you store in cloud kms
and a similar feature for kubernetes
secrets you can
encrypt kubernetes secrets using a cloud
kms
managed key as well the control plane
and the node the cluster infrastructure
itself
automatically upgrades itself by default
on gke
so if you create a cluster and just
leave it there and do nothing to it
it'll just keep upgrading itself and
keep itself in a in a good secure
security configuration we also offer
some control over how those upgrades
happen we have
different release channels that rapid
regular and stable that you can choose
to to really sort of dial up or down how
quickly those
updates are happening on your clusters
there's also additional features like
maintenance windows and exclusions
so let's talk a little bit about
compliance starting with the kubernetes
cis benchmark
so the center of internet security has
created a kubernetes benchmark
that tells you how to run kubernetes in
a in a hardened configuration
there's really a lot of settings in in
this benchmark
and we've done the hard work to
configure all those settings uh
to in uh the best possible way and
we've published our full results are for
gke and for
on-prem we've also developed a gke
specific cis benchmark that
basically just takes our hardening guide
and gives gives you that in a checklist
form
the infrastructure itself we've had a
bunch of compliance coverage there
so various standards listed here this is
for gke we're also working on
compliance coverage for infrastructure
in the other hybrid environments that
we're offering and we expect to make
some more announcements there soon
that's the infrastructure layer the next
layer up when you want to build an
application that's all
is itself compliant we're then
providing some solution guides such as
for pci for gke that
basically help you write that pci
application on top of gke
infrastructure and we're also working on
additional guides for additional
platforms and standards here too
so summing up this section endless
really does most of the work for you
here across all of the platforms
if you follow our guidelines for
multi-tenancy on gke there's a there's a
bit of extra information
in there about how to structure projects
how to put them in folders and how to
create vpcs
for on-prem and gke you can then follow
the hardening guides
to create the clusters themselves and on
top of that follow solution guides to
make the applications
that run in the clusters all the links
are provided here
so once you've made some clusters and
have some infrastructure to use
we really want to establish some
guardrails around that infrastructure to
make sure it's being used appropriately
the really key feature here is and those
conflict management
and this gives us the ability to manage
cross-cluster and cross-cloud
a lot of different policies and the idea
is
is to use a git ops model where
our infrastructure is code is is really
checked into our source control
so the idea there is that when we're
using source control to manage
infrastructure we have automatic review
we have a history we have a way to
templatize and create new
pieces of infrastructure easily so
looking at
how this works on uh for enthos we'd use
terraform to make the
the kind of base layer of infrastructure
things like projects and vpcs and
clusters
and then the next layer is where acm
comes in so acm config sync is generally
available across
all three and those platforms here and
that gives you the ability to
create namespaces configure rbac
security controls and also create
identities through service accounts
and really actually manage any
kubernetes object at scale across many
clusters across
all the hybrid environments here
you can also go even further and if you
like the declarative
kind of configures code approach you can
use it to also create
your gcp resources using gcp config
connector
the idea here is that you if you want to
if your application needs a pub sub
instance
you could write a piece of yaml that
goes along with all of your other yamls
for kubernetes
and you can cue control cube control
apply all of those
at once and have both the pods started
as well as the gcp resources that those
applications need
that's also ga across gke and on-prem
so acm config sync kind of sets us up in
this
base infrastructure security
configuration
policy controller is a feature that also
works across
all three environments here and it
allows us
to really control what the pods are
doing inside that that
cluster so the idea here is you want to
make sure that containers aren't doing
things like running his route on
accessing the host network on accessing
the host
host paths and doing other dangerous
things so we give you a really
comprehensive policy library that you
can apply to your clusters
and that policy library there's an
example here of uh not running as root
that policy library is written using
open policy agents gatekeeper
so a open source policy
language
so both of those features are available
across on
all the environments to use today
they're all ga there's a couple
of extra things we can talk about on gke
when you're running on gk itself
the first is all policies so all
policies sit above
all of your clusters above all of your
projects and they allow you to have some
like a macro policy control
across many objects so one thing you can
do is restrict
regions for resources so if you just
want to run in the us you can
make an old policy that says that for
google cloud
another thing you can do for your
kubernetes clusters is to restrict
how services are exposed to the internet
most organizations want to avoid someone
accidentally putting
a untested or a kind of poorly
configured application
accidentally on the internet and this is
a way to make sure that doesn't happen
uh with your gke clusters
another guardrail technology on gke
cloud
is vpc service controls this
technology allows us to have some
confidence that when we've put some
information in cloud storage or
other uh similar cloud uh resources on
gcp
that it's not going to easily be x-rated
exfiltrated by a bad guy
so there's a few scenarios that it
protects against imagine
someone accidentally messing up a access
control rule on a cloud storage bucket
and making it public for everyone to
read the vpc would still protect that
scenario
because there's a perimeter around there
that says those cloud storage buckets
should only be accessed from authorized
vpcs
in a similar fashion if one of your
compute resources happen
to get compromised the data wouldn't
it wouldn't it would also make it more
difficult to exfiltrate that data out
from
the out from the cloud by establishing
the same perimeter and only allowing the
traffic to
flow out on the authorized vpcs
so private gke clusters uh can be
established inside the perimeter so
they're not on the internet
you can also uh as do the same with a
container registry
with your container images and vpc
service controls
supports hybrid in that you can connect
your
hybrid on-prem networks by using cloud
internet interconnect or cloud vpn
so just summing up this section we want
to use acm to do the vast majority of
our policy
configuration and enforcement across our
hybrid infrastructure
and then on gke cloud we have some extra
controls that we can use to
do establish some extra guard rails
so that's uh that's the end of the
gunrail section i'm now going to hand it
over to samrat to talk about how to
secure our workloads
thanks greg we have now covered how to
configure a secure infrastructure and
set up guardrails
you are now ready to deploy workloads to
this secure landing zone
let us look at how you can secure
workloads with anthos
anthos provides tools to implement a
difference in depth architecture
or a zero trust architecture if you like
we we have provided here four steps that
you can use to secure
workloads on anthus the first being
the securing your build and deployment
pipelines
ensuring that that your entire supply
chain for your code from source
to your production is secure the second
is to ensure that all workloads deployed
to production
are appropriately isolated from the
internet
and from each other within your
production environment
you should also isolate your pods
on the node if multiple applications are
deployed
on a single cluster lastly
you want to ensure that services that
are exposed to the internet
are done so with appropriate protection
against internet-facing attacks
so let's go through the first step which
is to secure workloads
the objective of securing workloads is
to ensure that only trusted code
can be deployed to production to ensure
that
we recommend you lock down your cicd
pipelines
ensure that you use a secure base image
scan that base built image for known
vulnerabilities
google cloud's container registry
provides incremental
and continuous monitoring against a
known vulnerability database
the output of the scans are available as
metadata
with your pod the fact that you have
gone through all the above steps
can be asserted using binary
authorization
binary authorization allows you to
define a policy
that checks for attestation from each
step
of your build pipeline you can leverage
the tools
provided by gcp for building and
deploying
your containers or you can bring your
own build and deployment tools
as long as you they have a testers that
are trusted by binary authorization
only workloads that have the right
attestations can be deployed to
production
all deployment and denials are audited
by binary authorization
you can now trust the code running in
production
with a privileged identity
the next step is to isolate the deployed
code
from the internet this can be achieved
by ensuring that all clusters are
private
and any service that is exposed to the
internet is done so
using an internet facing load balancer
google cloud's load balancer provides
industry leading ddos protection
further you can configure web
application firewall
policies via cloud armor you can also
configure zero trust access
by your employees using identity aware
proxy
in addition to isolating the
applications from the internet
it is also necessary to isolate
workloads from
each other to prevent the lateral
movement of threats
we need to prevent lateral movements
over the network
but also between pods on the same node
anthos provides two technologies antho
service mesh
and kubernetes network policy to isolate
workloads on the network
anthos also provides two technologies gk
sandbox and app armor to isolate
applications on the node
let's learn more about these
technologies
a common approach with anthos is to
create clusters that are shared across
multiple teams
each team gets one or more namespaces
into which they deploy their application
workloads
thus namespaces form a natural boundary
for isolation
kubernetes network policy allows you to
isolate applications
on a single cluster based on name spaces
you can then define ingress and egress
rules based on
ip sitters or kubernetes objects such as
namespaces and labels
this approach is make can be called as
microsegment
micro segmentation it's a good approach
if you don't have too many exceptions to
manage
however in many cases we have seen
through experience
that there are a lot of east-west
communications between applications
and we implement shared services which
break isolation
thus we recommend using coarse grained
segments for mandatory controls
and defining fine-grained policies at
the application level
so you can define application level
policies and
an end to end zero trust access solution
using answer service mesh and identity
error proxy
with answer service mesh all
communications
are encrypted in transit further
all workload to workload communications
can be strongly authenticated authorized
and logged
workloads are authenticated using
certificates
instead of bearer tokens using mutual
tls
for authentication helps mitigate risk
of impersonation
and privilege escalation through replay
or man-in-the-middle attacks
asm also provides you uh with
context of our policies that allows you
to define
access controls based on peer request
and application contexts
for example you can state that only
credit card front-end can access credit
card back-end
you do this in terms of identities thus
credit card front-end can be deployed
anywhere and access policy remains the
same
irrespective of the network context of
credit card front-end
you can also state that credit card
front-end can only access pii
when it presents an end-user credential
i.e
a valid jwt token that has the right
claims
thus with answer service mesh you can
reduce the privilege
of the credit card front end with
respect to pii but also
ensure that all access to the credit
card data
happens only through the credit card
front end
on gcp we provide identity aware proxy
for authenticating and authorizing user
access
based on beyond core principles you can
also use
your own user authentication solution
that
with antho service mesh and you can do
all of this without changing your
application code
depending on your security profile and
what your application is
you might want a second layer of
isolation between your container
workloads
on a shared host anthos provides
two solutions for isolating pods on a
shared node the first one is gke sandbox
which is available on gcp
and the second is app armor which is now
in beta but is available on all
environments
gk sandbox is based upon an open source
project g-visor
that uses a user space kernel to
intercept and handle syscalls
thus you're reducing the interaction
with the host and reducing the attack
surface
we have now made this available to you
in anthos as gke sandbox which can be
enabled with a one line change
you can with app armor on the other hand
you can define the and reduce the
privileges
accessible by an application you need to
define application specific profiles
with app armor
so let us now look at summary of this
section
so we provide a defense in-depth
approach to secure your workloads
from securing your build and deployment
pipelines to isolating your applications
on the network
and we can do that with the difference
in depth approach using segmentation
and zero trust approach with answer
service mesh
and isolating your pods on a shared node
and finally we provide you the ability
to
protect your internet export services
using google cloud load
balancer and cloud armor
now let us look at the fourth step to
secure your applications with ansels
the fourth step is to enable monitoring
and detection for any incidents
now you have done your best to configure
everything securely
but how do you know you did it right in
order to know that we provide you
with the three layered stack going from
the bottom
we provide you with security health
analytics and web security scanner
that analyzes your configuration to
prevent
threats because of a misconfiguration
the layer above that
is a set of thread detection
capabilities which is the container
thread detection
event thread detection and access
transparency
access transparency enables you to
understand how
a google administrator may have accessed
your
resources and all of these information
is available through a single pane of
glass
while via the cloud security command
center
if you want to bring your own visibility
tools we allow you to do that
and you can integrate those tools at two
levels
you can export all your alerts events
and logs
that you need via pub sub for easy
integration
and use your own security visibility and
analysis tools
with anthos so let's understand a bit
more about
security health analytics security
health analytics
helps prevent threats by telling you
about problems before they get exploited
by an attacker
sha alerts you to misconfiguration
errors
in the context of gke an example is an
old cluster running an insecure
authentication mechanism
we also provide web security scanner
which identifies
issues with web applications the results
of the analysis
are displayed in cloud security command
center another
tool to understand is the container
thread detection
container thread detection helps you
detect potential attacks in real time
that by monitoring for suspicious
behavior
inside containers that may indicate that
they are compromised
these include things like downloading
and running new binaries
in addition to container thread
detection we also provide event thread
detection for
suspicions events and logs such as
traffic to
known bad domains and ips and crypto
mining
again you can see the findings in cloud
security command center
to summarize this section on gcp
we provide a number of tools to help you
analyze your posture and detect
incidents
this information is available in cloud
security command center
or a tool of your choice you can view
all your alerts in the cloud security
command center
and to recap what we have just covered
there are four steps to securing your
modern applications
using anthos you harden your
infrastructure
you then establish guard rails
once you have a secured landing zone you
can now
secure your workloads by uh securing
your deployment pipelines
and isolating your workloads in your
production environment
and finally you enable monitoring and
detection
to ensure that you have the right
posture and that you are
alerted on incidents and you can
enable this four-step workflow across
all your environments
whether it's gcp or on-premise
on aws and others in the future
thank you
you